"James": We'll talk about (e)!
The famous hard (e), well, it is one of the famous sports constants.
One of the most important constants, such as pi (pi), the golden ratio and square root of number 2.
Mathematical constants are the most important types of constants, and (e) is one of these constants.
(e) is a non-relative number, which equals: 2.178281828 ... etc
The hard problem (e) is that it is not an engineering identifier (using geometry).
Now, hard ebay (pi) is a fixed geometry identifier. It is the ratio between the circumference of the circle and its diameter.
Which was known to the ancient Greeks. Many of the geometric constants are due to them.
But the constant (e) is different, it does not depend on geometrical form, it is not dependent on geometry.
It is a mathematical constant linked to inflation and the rate of change, but what are they associated with?
Let's take a look at the issue that was used for the first time.
So, we will return to the seventeenth century, this is Jacob Bernoulli, who was interested in compound interest, which is to earn interest on your money.
Imagine you have a pound in the bank. It is a very generous bank, offering you 100% annual interest.
Thank you very much, Bank!
100% interest, so, after a year ...
You will own two pounds.
You have earned interest of LE, and you have the original pound in the bank ...
So, you have two pounds.
What if you are offered 50% interest every six months?
Is it better or worse?
Well, let's think about it ...
Well, you will start with a single pound, then I will offer you 50% interest every six months.
So, after six months, you will have a pound and a half.
Then you will wait for another six months, and you will earn 50% interest on the total amount of your money ...
And another 75 piasters ...
This will bring together what you already have, so that you have a profit and a quarter.
This is better!
it's better. But what happens if I do this more regularly?
What if I added interest every month?
I will offer you a benefit of 1/12 each month.
Is that better?
Let's think about it.
After the first month, it will be hit in the following number:
1 + 1/12
1/12, this is your advantage, and you will add the value of this interest to the pound you already own.
You will do this in the first month ...
Then in the second month ...
You will take this value and hit it again ..
In the same value.
And in the third month you will hit her again ...
and again.
You will do this twelve times a year.
Therefore, to calculate the total value in general,
This will be raised to S12.
The value will be 2.61 pounds.
So this is actually the best. The fact is that the more regular the interest is added ...
The better the result.
Let's try this every week. What if you added a profit every week? To what degree would this be better?
What I mean is that you earn 1/52 of the original amount per week. At the end of the year ...
You become 52 weeks, and the total amount will be 2.69 pounds.
It becomes better and better.
In general, you can notice a pattern that consists ... In general, the final form will be as follows:
You hit at (1 + 1 / n) ^ n. Please note that this pattern occurs.
So, here, n = 12 if you add interest every month, and n = 52 if you add interest every week.
If you add interest daily the value will be equal to 1 * (1 + 1/365) ^ 365
This is worth 2.71 pounds.
Well, it would be better if you added interest every second or every nanosecond.
What if I added interest consistently?
At every moment I earn a continuous benefit. How would this look?
This means that I have this formula here ...
It will become (1 + 1 / n) ^, where it is bound or goes to infinity.
This will be a constant interest that never ends. Now, what does this mean? What is this value?
This is what Bernoulli wanted to know.
He could not solve it, but he knew that it was between the two and three, so Euler managed to solve it 50 years after Bernoulli's idea.
Euler fixes everything!
"Brady": Is he the mother of Gauss?
James: Either Euler or Gauss, if you say that Euler or Gauss will be right.
And the value that Euler had reached was 2.718281828459 ... etc.
Brady: We were very close to this value when we added interest daily, right? The value was 2.71 when you added interest every day.
James: You're right, we were getting closer to value, right?
We were getting closer and closer to that value. So when adding daily, we were really close to it.
But if you do it forever, you will have a disproportionate number.
Euler called this value (e). He did not release his name on it, yet it is known as the Euler number.
"Brady": And what he named (e) then?
James: It was just a character. He may have already used A, B, C and D for something else.
is not it? So he used the next letter to them.
"Brady": a strange coincidence!
James: I think it's an amazing coincidence! I do not think he was arrogant and called it the first letter of his name.
But it is an amazing coincidence, the value called (e), and the number is Euler.
Brady: Would you call it G if you discovered it?
James: No, I did not call it C, but I was hoping someone else would call it C ...
I would agree to this.
Euler proved to be a disproportionate number.
He created a new formula for the calculation of (e), not the previous one, but a different one.
And have proved that it is a relative number, I will show you this quickly.
It was found that (e) is equal to two plus one ...
One Plus One On Two Plus One On One Plus One On One Plus One On Four Plus One On One Plus One On ...
One plus one on six ... And this goes on endlessly.
This break lasts forever, breaking is not finished. And you can see that it lasts forever
Because there is a pattern, this pattern remains true.
You have 2, then 1, 1, 4, 1, 1, 6, 1, 1, 8, etc.
And so you can see that the pattern goes on forever, and breaking it is an unfinished break.
This means that it is a non-relative number.
If it does not last forever, it will be finished, and if it is finished, you will be able to make it in a fractional form.
Euler also calculated the value of (e), and reached eighteen decimal places for this figure.
To do this use a different formula. I'll show it to you.
This time, find that (e) is equal to 1 plus ...
1 on the 1 plus 1 multiplier on the 2 plus 1 multiplier on the 3 multiplier
Plus 1 on the 4-stroke. This goes on forever.
It's a good formula. If you do not know the meaning of the multiplier, the multiplier is the sum of all the numbers.
For a given number, if it is multiplied by 4, it will equal 4 * 3 * 2 * 1.
Well, why is this so important? Because (e) is the natural language of inflation.
And I'll show you why. Well, let's draw a graph, where Y = e ^ X (Y = e ^ X)
Here, we take the basics of (e). So at zero, x = 0 (X = 0), the line will intersect at one.
So if you take a point on this graph, the value of the point will equal (e ^ X)
Therefore, this is important. The inclination at that point, the slope of the curve ...
At this point it equals (e ^ X), the space under the curve, which means the space under this curve ...
Even an infinite minus equals (e ^ X).
This is the only function that has this feature.
The value, inclination, and area at each point are equal.
So, at number 1, the value is equal to (e), because the value at this point is equal to e ^ 1. The value is equal to 2.718 and the slope is equal to 2.718 ...
The area below the curve is 2.718. This is important because it is a unique property.
Because of this characteristic, e becomes the natural language of differentiation.
Differentiation is the mathematics of the rate of change, inflation and spaces.
If you are interested in these things, if you write with (e), math becomes much simpler.
Because if you do not use e, you will get lots of complex constants
And then the math becomes chaotic. If you are trying not to use e,
You make things harder. It is the natural language of inflation.
Of course, the constant (e) is famous for combining all the famous mathematical constants together using this formula ...
Which is as follows: (e) Pi plus one equals zero (e ^ + + 1 = 0)
Here we get all the important mathematical constants in one formula.
We have (e), and we have the imaginary number (i), which is the square root of one negative, and we have the pi, and the numbers 1 and 0.
They have been compiled in one version ...
Which most people see as the most beautiful formula in mathematics.
I've seen her a lot, and I feel a bit bored. Do not put this in the video clip!